[Applaudissements]
sous les applaudissements il faut le sol
canadien en quête de paix et d'espoir
après des mois d'horreur
plus de 300 passagers ont déposé bagages
au manitoba en fin de journée heureux et
soulagé ils ont pris le temps de saluer
leur nouveau pays
attendait sa mère et sa soeur avec
impatience la suite
et ils ont été accueillis à bras ouverts
marina à confectionner des bouquets de
tournesol symbole d'espoir pendant cette
guerre en ukraine pour les remettre aux
nouveaux arrivants et les accompagner
les rassurer dans leur langue maternelle
et si
ils trouveront la paix ici mais doivent
maintenant se construire une nouvelle
vie
c'est dans ce centre d'accueil gérée par
le gouvernement provincial qu'ils auront
de l'aide pour trouver un logement un
emploi et des services d aide à
l'enfance
les défis sont nombreux et le
gouvernement fédéral reconnaît la
communité ici qui est très fort qui
vraiment accueillir ces gens et aussi
que la collaboration entre la province
et le fédéral va nous aider après
winnipeg deux autres vols nolisés
doivent atterrir au cours des prochains
jours l'un à montréal et l'autre à
halifax mais l'arrivée massive de
réfugiés iraniens se fait toujours
attendre plus de cent dix mille demandes
de visas ont été approuvés par le
gouvernement fédéral mais seuls 26000
craignait son arrivée en sol canadien et
si jérémie bergeron radio-canada
winnipeg